there are a lot of external factors that
can influence
um you know the microbiome I've put
together a few over here
um you know just to briefly talk about
how these kinds of excellent factors can
affect the micromise
so for example you know Studies have
shown that exercise independent of diet
can change the gut microbiome so it
exercise is not dependent on on diet
alone to change
um the microbiome and there are also
been studies showing that exercise
you know you know running running in a
park versus running in a treadmill in a
crowded gym has different effects on on
the microbiome so it's it's not only
where you exercise but how you exercise
um that matters
Studies have also shown that uh children
with pets at uh in at home have tend to
have a more diverse microbiome than uh
than children without so you know the
kind of um uh pets and animals that we
have at home also influences uh that
microbiome
we are you know we all know that uh food
plays a huge role in in shaping the
microbiome
but along with that I mean
um you know I'd like to talk a little
bit about the medications that uh and
and the significance that it has on on
the microphone
antibiotics
have uh you know quite drastic effect on
on the microbiome it it kind of destroys
a course of antibiotics kind of destroys
a large section of the microbiome and
what what the Hebrews post that is
um you know could be very different
could be dominated by one or two species
which can then go cause uh problems in
in the human system
um it's it's not only that it's uh not
only antibiotics I mean any kind of
medication that we're taking has an
effect on
um on how the bacteria interacts with uh
with the chemical components um in the
medication
um for example titanium dioxide which is
a coloring agent that is used in in most
uh tablets you know it gives the tablets
white color and that itself has been
shown to change the microbiome
um in a certain way
so
um it's not only the negative effect you
know sometimes uh there could be uh
there could be positive interactions
between the microbiome and and
um
chemical medication for example
for example metformin
um metformin's efficacy changes the
changes the microbiome metformin's
efficacy is is based on how the
microbiome is is is interacting
um with it so the way the microgram
interacts with with any kind of
mitigation is is also very significant
uh like I mentioned I mean it the
microbiome changes it's it's transient
it it it changes based on
um
um on our external environment and how
our lifestyle changes
um typically what what I have seen is it
changes over a period of of three to six
months
um if if you're a frequent traveler if
you have um evidences of medication it
could yeah it could change much earlier
uh than this but for an average
individual it's it's anywhere between
three to six months time
um
though the simple way to improve it is
is you know is is by the methods that
I've shown uh on on the slide
um but but seeing this I mean it is
um it is not as as simple as this I mean
it it just gets complicated with with
different types of of uh diseases
in terms of of diet disease I just
wanted to bring out a very powerful uh
example I mean the uh silver has that
tribe uh they had a Tanzanian tribe um
and they have the most diverse set of
microbiome that is that is known to us
right now and this is because they have
the most diverse set of food
um that they will eat over over in in a
period in in a given year
um this is because of the fruits and
vegetables that they eat are very
seasonal
um and and also the kind of meat that
they eat is also very seasonal so
because of that they have a lot of
variety in the food that they're eating
and hence have a lot of diversity in in
the microbiome the
it's it's because of the diversity that
now
um scientists think that the tribe does
not have any known case of diabetes
obesity blood pressure or cardiovascular
diseases so you know that's that's how
much the nutrition can affect the on the
gut and and how the cut microbiome
actually plays a role
um in in any kind of disease formation
Okay so
ninety percent of our lifestyle and
non-communicable diseases I know
diseases like diabetes arthritis obesity
cardiovascular disease
um can be linked back now to to our
microbiome I'm just going to go through
a few examples of of this so that
um
um you can get a
brief understanding of how these
interactions are taking place
the
in and you have to do this the thing
that um that we're trying to do is is go
from a dysbiotic state and you know and
get them back to a new biosis state now
when
you know the difference between this
biosis and new biases is quite simple I
mean it you can just look at at the
diversity of the microorganisms and and
determine uh the states I mean in in the
spouses the number of microbes that are
present
um in the gut would be very very less uh
as compared to uh in in the UVS state
for example
um if we were to look at the profile the
gut microbiome of any individuals you
would you would and healthy individual
you would see anywhere between 1500 to
2000 different organisms
but uh when we profile the Batman of
individuals who are suffering from a
chronic disease for a long time then the
number of microbes that are present in
the gut would be lesser than thousands
of B uh anywhere in the range of 700 to
800 so the lesser the number of
organisms the more problematic it is for
the human system and and this is the
dysbiotic state
um there are other ways of of looking at
it I mean you can you can look at the
major
um
the major failures of bacteria that is
from acute bacterial release
protobacteria and actinom bacteria look
at those ratios and see how it is uh
changing
um nowadays we you can also measure the
metabolites
um and and you would see in a dysmatic
state the net of the uh the short chain
fatty acid or other beneficial
metabolites are actually uh low in
number as compared to any viruses State
mostly significantly the opportunistic
uh bacteria and fungus usually go up in
number in the disperses
so similarly when when we look at
obesity and and we look at the obese
dark microbiome versus the lean gut
microbiome the
um the first thing that you notice over
there is the diversity is very very low
because the diversity is is low
um in the obese
pain of these individuals you would see
decrease satiately increased
inflammation
um and also there would be a decrease in
in burning of fat
um so the problem is compounded by
people wanting to eat more because
there's no signal going to the plane
saying that
um you know there is enough food in the
back end and we need to stop eating
um and
all the food that is eaten and all the
fat that is eaten is not getting burnt
um
uh fast enough because of the microbiome
and and
in the normal State I mean say shady is
normal I mean after a certain amount of
food with a signal going to the brain
saying that enough uh don't eat anymore
and there is uh you know proper
metabolization of both carbs and and
fats
foreign
disrupted microbiota or not only causes
obesity it can also affect reproductive
health so it it has an impact both on
the mother
um you know as well as the future of
spring as well
so during
um the the dis you know with the dispa
disrupted microbiota
um during the
pregnancies stages they could be chances
of of miscarriage there could be chances
of the mother
having prolonged periods of of diabetes
um and eventually they could be an
adverse
um
health issue with with the child so this
could be The Offspring could could have
unnecessary weight gain could
um could also start developing allergies
and and other
um
another autoimmune disorders as well
because of the disrupted microbiota
during the reproductive